bonjour à qui ai-je dans un bon c'est
christophe ritoo je suis le chef des
matières in sports à montréal depuis 20
ans et cette semaine c'est une spéciale
au sommet spécial pour nous c'est la
saint patrick
donc c'est toujours sur plus grosse
semaine de l'année et donc beaucoup de
nourriture beaucoup de plats irlandais
revampé de l'otan de façon à beaucoup de
bruits guinness et il se passe le jour
de la saint patrick
l'équipe un comble dimanche aux comores
ce matin pour le petit déjeuner en
breakant bonne chère gros brunch qui
commence le matin de 7 heures ou key
surtout surtout amusé car 10h30 11h vie
pendait d'achat rageant d'âge avec lui
la clientèle
après le monde aujourd'hui le menu
zélandais comme spéciale qui consiste à
1000 dimanche soir c'est sampras est ce
nous ressaisir 7 et vendait ce qu'on a
rejoint adapter notre façon de motiver
zapatero s'est passé c'est assez simple
mais c'est un bon produit
avec ce bond est bon lit du vrai messie
et soient plus seulement pourra plus
changer un peu las cases est devant moi
c'est le boeuf braisé à la baisse on
risque survie de chou braisé pommes de
terre vapeur avec des carottes et des
panneaux rigides son saut de suite on
finit avec du miel du nord dans le
suspect est chez moi ça prendrait
commence à prendre quatre à cinq ans
parce que pendant 2h 2h30 bouillir
tranquillement avec des épices la
guinness du jus de boeuf un petit peu de
vin sous les 6000 ça serait plus du gain
qui voyez et après on enlève le peuple
plus de la viande c'est un biais
haussier
on la mélange un plat avec du plus
puissant un petit peu de miel de whisky
curve eau pendant deux heures et après
c'est la viande se libère ça a tellement
les rangs que je vais la ramenez vos
bureaux pour le partage avec des
qualités tout ceci juste pour finir par
mois 2 comment retrouver la saint
patrick buros part à la maurienne donc
ça pour nous avec vos clients qui
viennent
décosse ne rien conclure qu'il n'y a
plus de parti ou beaucoup de bosses
tombe bien aussi mais pourtant à bord
d'une grosse star game il préfère passer
une amélie si donc tout est habillé en
vert tout en bois la main tout le monde
à la maison
un jour ma fiche de police y travaillent
ça fait plaisir
merci à vous